bienvenidos de vuelta ahora los voy a
introducir al concepto de momento y la
letra que designamos en física para el
momento es o al menos en mecánica es la
letra p que es la letra p y quizás es la
letra p pues porque ya utilizamos semen
para masa que son una idea todavía más
fundamental y quizás tengas una idea
general de que es el momento pero más o
menos es lo que como por ejemplo uno uno
tiene la idea de que si va a un tipo muy
grande y va corriendo muy rápido
entonces tiene un buen de momento verdad
tienen lleva mucho momento obtiene mucho
momento quizás debería decirlo en
comparación a que si tenemos a un tipo
más flaco o pequeño y que corre a la
misma velocidad pues entonces podríamos
intuir que ese tipo pues tiene menos
momento que el tipo grande verdad quizás
no no no tengas una cantidad precisa
para medir el momento pero tienes la
sensación de que esto es cierto entonces
realmente el modo el momento lo vamos a
definir como la masa
por la velocidad aunque es la masa por
la velocidad
entonces si tienes a un tipo muy grande
que va a una a una velocidad alta pues
entonces lleva mucho momento verdad si
tienes a un tipo pues a lo mejor más
flaco pero con esa misma velocidad puede
llevar a una menor un menor momento
verdad
en pocas palabras uno podría pensar al
momento como que tan poco placentero
sería ser golpeado por ese objeto que
lleva a lo mejor mucha más hay mucha
velocidad verdad esa es una forma de
pensarlo si lleva muy poca velocidad y
muy poca masa pues a lo mejor no nos
hará mucho daño ahora cómo podemos
relacionar el momento con todo lo
anterior que hemos estado viendo
recordemos que la fuerza la fuerza es
igual a la masa masa por la aceleración
masa por aceleración pero nosotros
sabemos muy bien que la aceleración es
el cambio de la velocidad entre el
cambio del tiempo entonces la fuerza
es igual a la masa por el cambio en la
velocidad por el cambio en la velocidad
entre el cambio en el tiempo verdad muy
bien entonces qué es lo que podemos
hacer la masa vamos a suponer que si
tenemos un objeto moviéndose pues no va
a perder masa verdad más esencialmente
se va a conservar la masa y entonces qué
es lo que vamos a tener esta masa pues
podemos meterlo dentro del campo de esta
de esta letra delta que es de cambio
entonces esto es el cambio de la masa
por la velocidad verdad sobre el cambio
en el tiempo y entonces que es a lo que
hemos llegado con esta expresión que la
fuerza es igual al cambio del momento
cambio del momento entre el cambio del
tiempo muy bien entonces también
podríamos ver que la fuerza es igual al
cambio del momento entre
el cambio del tiempo y esto es muy
importante porque observemos que si no
tenemos alguna fuerza externa es decir
está efe es cero quiere decir que no hay
cambio en el momento solo podría cambiar
si tenemos una fuerza externa que actúa
sobre nuestro objeto así que el cambio
en el momento o más bien esta relación
es muy importante y podríamos decir que
si no hay fuerzas externas al sistema
entonces el momento se conserva verdad
se conserva constante ahora otro
concepto importante o relacionado con
esto es el concepto de impulso y quizás
tienes una muy buena idea de qué es esto
pero vamos a definirlo de la siguiente
forma la fuerza perdón aquí la fuerza
por el cambio en el tiempo es el impulso
vamos a denotar lo con j&j y que este es
el impulso muy bien y esto realmente no
no quiero detallar mucho me interesa más
trabajar con el momento
bueno esto es por si a lo mejor te lo
encuentras en algún examen ahora
utilizando esta fórmula la fuerza es el
cambio en el momento entre el cambio en
el tiempo verdad y esto multiplica al
cambio en el tiempo y esto es igual al
impulso que es jota entonces estos
cambios en el tiempo se cancelan y
entonces el cambio del momento es igual
al impulso muy bien esto es igual al
impulso y esto pues tendrá unidades pues
las mismas que tiene el momento verdad
el momento es masa por velocidad que
sería kilogramos metros sobre segundo
verdad kilogramos metros sobre
kilogramos por metro sobre segundo o que
es lo mismo que newton por segundo y
esas son las unidades del momento ok
entonces con esto principalmente este
realmente no es tan importante para lo
que vamos a trabajar sino más bien esta
relación de la fuerza con el momento y
vamos a utilizarlo para resolver
problemas de momento
digamos que tenemos no sé un carro
digamos que tenemos aquí un carro
ok más o menos uno viejito parece
ahí está en nuestro carro
y digamos que este carro tiene una masa
de 1000 kilogramos y tenemos una masa de
este carro de 1000 kilogramos
ok y lleva una velocidad digamos de 9
metros por segundo y digamos que va en
esta dirección ahora supongamos que a lo
mejor el conductor que vaya adentro
no se da cuenta que aquí adelante
tenemos un camioncito que no se podría
hacer un camión de helados o que se yo
aunque ella y lo tienen
y entonces y aquí este camión lleva
está digamos que este camión está
estacionado y tiene una masa digamos del
doble de 2.000 kilogramos y lleva una
velocidad cero es decir este camión está
detenido entonces digamos que este carro
no se da cuenta y choca con él con este
camión y se atora es decir cuando ocurre
este esta colisión llegamos a algo así
no a nuestro carro que termino embonando
con el camión
ok algo así
algo así terminaron juntos muy bien
entonces esto por supuesto tendrá una
masa conjunta de 3.000 kilogramos verdad
entonces una vez que se atora digamos
cuál es la pregunta que te planteo es
cuál es la velocidad de este carro con
el camión vamos a llamarle el carro
camión después de nuestro choque muy
bien entonces lo importante aquí es que
no hemos o no no hay ninguna fuerza
externa que actúe sobre esta sobre este
choque quiere decir que el momento final
que tenemos en este en este caso debe
ser igual a la suma de los momentos que
teníamos antes entonces cómo calculamos
el momento que lleva este auto pues
tendremos la masa del auto digamos por
su velocidad por la velocidad del auto y
hay que sumarle hay que sumarle el
momento que lleva este
este cambio digamos la masa del camión
por la velocidad del camión y esto
cuánto nos da
aquí tenemos una masa de mil kilogramos
mil kilogramos que multiplica a la
velocidad que es 9
la masa de nuestro bueno esto fue del
carro verdad la masa del camión sería
2000 por la velocidad del camión que es
0 entonces esto esto no cuenta eso vale
0 y qué es lo que obtuvimos obtuvimos
1000 por 9 que son 9000 que es kilogramo
metro sobre el segundo verdad esta es la
cantidad de momento que llevamos en esta
digamos de este lado ahora cuál es el
momento que tenemos del lado derecho
pues
esto debe ser 3000
por la velocidad por la velocidad que no
sabemos cuál es esto debe ser igual a
9000 verdad porque tenemos justo la
conservación del momento no estamos
involucrando ninguna fuerza externa
verdad así que el momento se mantiene
constante y entonces uno puede
simplemente despejar porque la velocidad
sería 9000 entre 3000 sería 3 metros
sobre segundo muy bien entonces y esto
tienen bastante sentido verdad tenemos
un carro que le lleva a cierta velocidad
y al chocar con este auto se incrusta y
digamos suman sus masas pero por haber
chocado y como se mantiene el momento
entonces estos nueve metros sobre
segundo van a reducirse a simplemente
tres metros sobre segundo ahora bien en
los próximos vídeos haremos muchos más
problemas sobre el momento y nos
saltaremos a calcular el momento en dos
dimensiones ok nos vemos pronto